votre vidéo vous est présenté par
victoria tirer talents.com vous avez
plus de 5000 follower sur vos réseaux
sociaux
venez nous rejoindre et devenez
influenceurs grâce à victoria tirer
talents.com
[Applaudissements]
allez messieurs
bien sûr on aura tous les chroniqueurs 1
qui vont concourir pour être notre
candidat à la présidence puisque on va
faire nos propres primaires ce soir vous
allez en sortir 5 puisqu'on a lancé un
sondage il y en a cinq qui vont
concourir pour être le candidat un mot à
dire la france vous avez 15 secondes
mathieu est bien coté chercher ou un
mais je pense un mot une phrase banale
quand même cher français je pense qu'il
faut voter pour moi j'ai été élu
meilleur chroniqueur la saison dernière
et j'entends le rester cette année
[Musique]
oui je deviens fou
jean michel maire
ce candidat et vous quel candidat ils
vous le candidat de je veux tout
simplement moins que le candidat de
l'amour vous convier dans un monde de
violence de dollats de dissension de
conflit que c'était rare y en a trop de
polémiques
moi j'aimerais bien qu'on se rassemble
et qu'on s'aime voilà parce qu'il ya
beaucoup de choses à faire
ouais j'ai la peau a été reçu avec des
capitaux à vous organiser quelque chose
ce sont vous avez vous avez très envie
de danser tous ces si on va faire la
danse des élections c'est ça la à chaque
fois françois quand vous irez voter on
est vrai que nos actifs dans l'urne
prochain dans dix ans vous nous faites
attention c'est pas dit non mais j'adore
elle est cassée attend avec impatience
le discours de capital j'espère que
nicolas sato à sarko ni n'ont rien à ce
qui va voir ce qu'il a perdu une roue
bravo à lui de 10 minutes pour ça que
j'ai pris de bulma 3 1 à 3 il y en a
quatre merci ça va les yeux les deux
rivaux alors tel candidat est vous les
français les téléspectateurs vous
regarde les contrées les spectateurs
vous écoute bonsoir à tous
en mai déjà
bonsoir à tous sur la tête de ma mère
aux dirigeants philippe poisson en mai
et vous alors je vous le dis est
vraiment de sens et c'est de plus en
plus godbout bon alors
un jour gilles verdez l'avenir doit
devenir beau gosse ouais comme quoi les
miracles sont partout montreraient des
beaux gosses à l'occasion pour comparer
vous verrez bien analysé doute raison
non mais il n'a pas alors vous quelques
ondées à cala calmos arabe oui je vais
calme parce que vous verrez que j'ai
changé et je serai le candidat de ceux
qui souffrent je serai candidat de ceux
qui sont seuls avec vous je me battrai
contre l'injustice
si vous êtes un orphelin du bonheur
votez pour moi
[Applaudissements]
vous imaginez en plein débat david
pujadas mais seraient baptisés jadi
bleus d'emma télévisée mon frère en cinq
minutes il arrête tout capucine à l'avs
alors moi j'ai réfléchi pendant l'année
vous avez réfléchi
les gars ça fait 2010 à lui est pas
arrivé
ben non mais figurez-vous que j'avais
pas quoi dire donc j'ai décidé de parler
votre coeur oui cher public de mon coeur
je suis jeune
en phase avec la vie sans doute parfois
approximative mais était séparé tout
c'est promis c'est pour moi très doué
braden de ma mère avec un discours comme
ça au mieux les délégués de classe
jean-luc à l'isi chers amis je n'avais
prévu un discours pour vous convaincre
de voter pour moi et puis j'ai écouté
mes camarades et en les écoutant je me
suis dit que ça servait à rien de faire
un discours je pense que tout ce qu'ils
ont dit ça vous donne envie de voter
pour moi
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]